I think the best way to prove your your
value is to work is to learn is to
absorb to be a sponge you always want to
outwork your potential you know as hard
as you believe you can work you can work
harder than that and that's what I tried
to do when I first came in the league
but you know basketball is such a direct
competition sport at me coming in at 17
I hated when like my teammates would say
you know I get hit with an elbow right
Shaq would hit me with an elbow in
practice I always had that extra chip on
my shoulder so like every day in
practice for me was really trying to
annihilate everybody that was that I was
playing against I wanted to prove you
don't need to babysit me and so it's
always that competitive nature the work
ethic and curiosity My Philosophy was a
very simple one you know Rudy was one of
my favorite films growing up after
watching that film I come to understand
if I could work that hard with my career
be and I made a promise to myself from
that day that I was going to work that
hard every single day so that when I do
retire I have no regrets and that was
the most important thing for me is to
leave no stone unturned get better every
single day and if I live that way then
over time you know I'd have something
that was beautiful that was my
philosophy it seems like a pretty simple
one but you know if you live your life
to just get better every single day and
do that for 20 years I mean what do you
have Hey Kevin Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I was making 300 bucks a month
I quit on my business partner and the
thing that saved me was studying the
stories of super successful
entrepreneurs so I hope that this story
today helps give you the motivation you
need because I still needed to myself so
today let's learn how you can focus your
mind
Joy
rule number two is focus on your goal
with Tom bilyeu you've got two choices
in life choice one you can become
somebody else Choice two you can become
yourself now I really wish that there
was only one choice but in truth there's
not and most people choose to try to
become someone else because it's a road
map it's points in a direction you see
someone you respond to something you
admire them you want to be like them and
in that process
you've made your decision in that
process you've decided to become
somebody else you have mistaken the
finger for the Moon instead you need to
understand that being inspired by
somebody does not mean to become that
person to become that which inspires you
it is to understand fundamentally what
is it about that thing that excites you
what is it what is its essence
we find its Essence then you can find
out how it would apply to you becoming
you
and as Zen she says flower does not
think about competing with the flower
next to it it just blooms and that's
really your job is to see the outside
world to see the flower next to you to
understand the amazing things that are
happening all around you all of the
incredible people and the essence of
what they have and what it is that
they've done to bring inside yourself
and find out what does that look like
when it's me not what do I look like
when I'm them and once you understand
the difference between that then you can
really begin to be something unique you
can become that thing that you were
meant to be that thing that makes you
feel alive and whole and that's it
that's the secret you're just trying to
be something not that's just inspiring
to other people but that you actually
want to wake up every day and be and
that's the thing about it there's no
escaping you whatever you become a lie
the truth somebody else yourself
whatever it is
you spend every day of your life there
and as Albert Einstein said everybody's
a genius but if you judge a fish by its
ability to climb a tree it will live its
whole life believing that it's stupid
and that's what confuses people
believe that they're dumb because
they're not finding their path they're
not defining Things based on what
excites them and what they want to live
with every day they're just looking to
what the outside world says is good and
I think it's incredible that there are
other people doing things that are so
extraordinary that we aspire to be like
that but you have to understand the
difference between being like someone
and trying to actually beat them
so if what inspires you is that somebody
works hard work hard if what inspires
you is that somebody gets up every time
they fail get up every time you fail if
what you like is that they're themselves
with all their weird
eccentricities and quirks then be true
to your eccentricities and quirks but
don't try to embody their eccentricities
and quirks that's the surest way to
become the fish that thinks it's stupid
because it's being judged by trying to
climb a tree
foreign
said when 99 of the people doubt your
idea you're either Gravely wrong or
about to make history
and that's the terrifying part you're
not gonna know
you're not going to know the difference
but if you're chasing somebody else's
path if your whole game is emulation if
your whole game is to mimic that which
inspires you you will never find the
thing that's real about you and look I
don't know about you but I can be wrong
I can be Gravely wrong I can have people
think me an idiot and try something and
fail as long as it was true to me
because then the lesson that I'm going
to learn is going to apply it's going to
take me another step closer to actually
being the person that I want to become
that I want to live with every day
foreign
[Music]
who I want to be
so look inward identify your path
identify what excites you and go after
it as if your life depends on it because
in truth it does rule number three is
ignite your fire with Lisa Nichols it's
gonna cost you way more money than you
thought you would invest it's gonna cost
you some friends who couldn't make the
entire Journey with you it's going to
cost you that that sense of oh my God I
gotta leave I Gotta Die to the old me to
allow the new to be born to my future
it's going to cost you something this is
the year for reset this is the year for
restart this is the year for reignite
this is the year for repeat the things
that you love this is the year for
recommit this is the year for redesign
this is the year for re-engage this is
the year for restart this is that year
I stopped by to ignite your fire I
stopped by to have you confront fear I
stopped by to have you look at what it's
cost you and to make a bold declaration
the next time it rise up you rise up a
little bit higher than it
foreign
I stopped by for you to no longer make
fear your enemy make fear your fuel
stop by to redefine fear
to redefine it because fear is an
emotion like any other emotion fear is
an emotion like love like compassion
fears and emotion we just gave it more
power
we just gave him more power compassion
oh that's nice fear
we made we gave it a meaning
some of you know you've heard this
before that fear is false
evidence appearing real
time to literally biohack the impact
that fear has had on
your fear no longer becomes your
Fortress fear becomes your fuel
fear is that thing that puts you forth
fear is the thing that reminds you oh I
need to go get more information oh fear
will keep you up at night studying fear
will take you to a cultural Mentor fear
will cause you to eat a slice of humble
pie
repeat after me
I am ready
for my next best season
because I know
that I am the author
of my autobiography
I am the designer
of my own destiny
I am writing my life story
writing a life story
that I'm going to love reading
others will be inspired by
inside on one page
they'll read my fear
face
they'll know I did it anyway
it's a whole fear in one hand
and passion and the other
and Lee
and Lee and leap every time every time I
ask that each of you hold me accountable
to my contribution on this planet
turn to someone to say don't let me off
the hook also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is grow consciously
with Tony Robbins when you look at what
makes people really feel alive there's
very few things that compete with
growing and of course giving and where
does growth come from first of all
without it life feels pretty dead inside
we're all trying to Mark something that
gives us a sense of aliveness people ask
me all the time what does it really take
to be happy so I can give it to your own
word progress progress equals happiness
did you ever achieve a goal and after
you achieve it said is this all there is
so you got to think to yourself why
don't I stay happy I like I work so hard
at this why does it stay fulfilled
because life is not about you just
getting your goals my teacher gymnastics
you say something that was so profound
when I was 17 years old he said what you
get will never make you happy doesn't
matter what you did I'm become
very sad see ultimately we have
challenges so that we can grow and we
have growth so we have something to give
and it's the giving that makes us feel
alive when they're growing that makes us
still alive and so if you don't grow
consciously here's the challenge part
life will show up and give you something
to grow from
from SAS fulfillment aliveness is not
one thing you did one time it's
it's saying I love you it's stepping up
it's doing what's right even when no one
else will rewards you
are the things growing at
home and actually there's only one
it's eliminated revolution of nothing
else
is always easy
there was failure
to learn something because that learning
leads to growth that grows
in something or give something to
yourself others your
or to have something that's meaningful
so where are you not
[Music]
growth just to find happiness for Joy or
meaning in difficult situations those
types of progresses will lead to an
extraordinary quality of life
how's that for an uplifting message one
way you know you're growing is one thing
that used to be to be seen little to you
give yourself 20 30 minutes every day
listen to something that inspires you or
read a book something with philosophy or
strategy they can improve the quality of
your life your career your family your
happiness your children enjoy something
because great ideas have to be pursued
answers don't interrupt you they have to
be pursued
but now when I focused enough caring
enough compassion enough Drive you'll
find answers that'll help you to grow
and if you don't life's gonna challenge
you anyway so why not push yourself out
there with some new goals some new
desires that you proactively create that
stimulate the growth that make you
fulfilled and instead of expecting the
joy lasts forever just know life is
progress baby growth is everything gross
will give you more to give and as you
give more you'll love more you'll love
yourself you'll love your life and
you'll be a source of generous loves to
others rule number five is activate your
greatness with Eric Thomas you're
already in pain get a reward for it
[Music]
so why would you go through all that
pain and not get something for it
to put all those hours in and not
transfer those hours to something else
it doesn't make sense not to recycle the
pain and get wealth or a successful life
a successful spouse like whatever have
kid whatever it is I was like it can't
eat here
I've read the books I've gone to the
conferences I went to the classes I I
got the degrees like it can't end with
just life is going to deal me this head
you still have to do life regardless of
how you come into life if you come in
great if you come in poorly it does not
matter you have to do life and if you're
smart you do life on your terms and you
don't let life make you do it on his
terms
I'll do whatever it takes to keep this
Freedom I'll do whatever it takes
so the first thing you got to do is you
got to get out of your feelings you know
you woke up got into it with your spouse
or your kids call with something that
was going on or you were sick and so I
think for most people they go wrong
because they think it's a feeling when
execution is a fact
there are going to be difficult times in
your life there are going to be times
where you have every reason to make an
excuse absolutely but that won't serve
you
and I look at Coleman was like yo not
you didn't necessarily live to be a
hundred but the time you had on Earth
put in work and then you went and
dominated one area and then you start
coming over and say now I'm coming into
some other areas
bring my greatness over here and I'm
gonna kill it and that's all I'm saying
to people greatness is in you activated
like I wake up every day with this all
right I'm gonna win a Nobel Prize and
it's not about the Nobel Prize it's not
about Norway it is about if LeBron and
Michael Jordan are playing for the
finals and uh Gretzky is playing for the
Stanley Cup and somebody else is playing
for the penny like my my pennant is the
Nobel Prize because you don't get that
without helping millions of people get
from one place in their lives you know
to another
and so what I do is I figure out where
you are and I dare you to come out of
where you are to if nobody ever
influence you where would you want to be
like what what do you want what do you
want to do not what they want you to do
if you could dream
like what would your best life look like
for you if you didn't have to impress
your mom or your dad you didn't have to
go to college because your parents went
to college
like what would you really do and then
if they can tell me and if I can figure
out
where you want to go at that point I can
snatch your current reality and help you
to build a new reality to help you to
get where you go so for me it's I got to
get in here and I gotta get in here and
if you let me into these two spaces I
can get you wherever you're trying to
get to
[Music]
you gotta understand
the opportunities that you have you know
I've been to third world countries where
it does not matter how early you wake up
it does not matter how long you stay up
it doesn't matter what your skill sets
are it doesn't matter you don't have
opportunity you have people all over the
world who are dying to get here
literally dying to get here
you have an opportunity of a lifetime
and where much is giving much is
required
why you got opportunities you got banks
that you can get loans from uh you can
go online and sell stuff from online
like you don't have to have a store
anymore a storefront like you can
literally become rich from your watch so
it's like yo instead of you looking at
everything that's not look at what is
so absolutely this is some stuff to
complain about one thousand percent it's
a whole bunch of stuff I can complain
about it's a lot of stuff that I can be
angry about but I didn't realize how
quick life was
because life is short I don't have time
to focus on what's not
I've got to focus on what he is then get
up and go get it
and for me it's like guys I need you to
understand where you are
we are looking for opportunity and we
have it and so if you can lock in I need
you to get focused I need you to get
locked in I'm too scared not to try like
I'm too scared not to take the risk the
only thing standing in your way is you
that's it
[Music]
doesn't do what you think they should do
and you go off but then you give you a
pass like you don't go off on you but
when are you gonna go in the mirror and
check yourself like why are you giving
yourself a pass why are you giving
yourself an hour
and you didn't finish school or you
didn't write the book or you didn't do
the album or or you didn't go back to
school or you told yourself you was
going to lose weight and you just let
you just let yourself off the look like
well you didn't do it for you I'm saying
no do me a favor with that same energy
you use to hold somebody else
accountable hold yourself accountable
because here's the deal you hold me
accountable and I change how do you
benefit from that
use that same energy you use on others
I'm not saying don't hold people
accountable but I'm saying use that same
energy on yourself and you be shocked
how much further you're being like if
you just punish yourself you put you on
punishment
so for me it's not this is happening
this has happened this is happening I
look at it James Sabbath this is where
the Magic Johnson's the Larry birds like
this is where the Michael Jordans are
made
this is where the real Ballers this is
where the real Ballers come out this is
what I signed up for this is what all
the weights were for this is the eating
right this is getting up early going
this is the trainers like this is why I
went to this school this is why I got
this coach like this I long for this and
I live for this
when I see trials and tribulations I go
it's showtime with a real Eric Thomas
with a game seven Eric Thomas please
stand up activate Grand Slam boom it's
out of here so I just look at it as hey
if you want to complain go for it I will
rise to the level of the challenge
[Music]
we'll do it rule number six is go hard
with David Goggins when that alarm clock
goes off at four or five in the morning
your mind says no you just say this is
what we do
is what we do now because to get to
where you want to go
the amount of pain involved I'm not
saying physical I'm not saying you got
to break yourself off the amount of
mental pain
how many times you're gonna have to do
something that you don't want to do
to get to where you want to go
when I was 297 pounds and I was fat as
hell trying to be a Navy SEAL the
scariest thing in the world to me even
to this day
was that that could have been the rest
of my life
I thought then I was trying hard that's
the scariest thing in the world I
thought then 297 pound working for
Ecolab spring for cockroaches making a
thousand dollars a month
I thought that was me at my 100
potential
come to find out
a few years later
I wasn't anywhere near that 106 pounds
less graduate Navy still training we
don't do all these other things looking
back on that that was me trying hard
that's why people got to understand what
is in us we have no idea until we start
trying hard and I mean really trying
hard when you're obsessed with hey this
is my new Norm my new Norm is that wow
this isn't always fun
it's not always meant to be fun and
that's when you know you're trying hard
is that and so people listening to us
that maybe are at 20 or 30 you know
I'm going hard I'm going Max and yet
they're not seeing the results like how
do they actually Shake themselves out of
that
we're all in a battle with our own
brains that's all life is it's the most
probably in the world is your own brain
it can work for you or against you and
it's as opposed to focusing on all those
bad things that happen all the things
you didn't have the people that called
you names all the stuff in Brazilian
again and you start thinking wait a
second I just visualize this and now I
can take it to the next level Next Level
because the visualization got you
through
it did
and I was able to visualize the end
of course so when I was 297 I was all
fat and out of shape and I couldn't run
a quarter mile and I was drinking
milkshakes and eating boxes of donuts I
visualized man how would it feel
for a brief moment
I was so there were 22 guys that
graduated I watched this segment on TV
about these guys going through Navy SEAL
training and I couldn't even I I won a
great swimmer I was afraid of the water
all this crap man
good
but at the very end it says 22 guys as
command officers up there and he gives
this great speech
I was like man I wonder so I started
visualizing me being the 23rd guy in
these dress whites sitting there with
these guys getting that Navy SEAL you
know graduating this Navy still training
I was like God so I put myself there I
was like my that's an amazing feeling I
put myself there at 297 not even able to
do anything that these great men were
doing
I said man
one it lasts for one second
get that certificate you walk across the
stage and what's next but I didn't know
that there my mind wasn't I thought I'd
live in that moment forever so I said
wow man if I could just feel like that
if I could feel like you and what would
that feeling you wanted so bad no Sweet
Victory I wanted to win not like beat
somebody else
it wasn't about that I I just wanted to
go the distance
everything in my life when something got
hard I quit if it was reading that's
where you know I wasn't great at reading
I wasn't great at writing so I just quit
I couldn't catch on as fast as you I had
to work harder than you so I quit
you know I wasn't great at things so I
quit you know I'm I'm not good at this
like man if I could just go that
distance that extra mile to just go just
to finish I want to finish I want to
feel Victory and victory for me wasn't
winning it was just finishing
so I said you know what
I could feel like these guys feels it
will change my life but what I realized
the best feeling I had was when I was by
myself trying to lose this weight I had
to lose it in literally less than three
months 106 pounds in less than three
months
and literally I started feeling victory
just by putting myself in the battle
it wasn't about going to Navy SEAL
training it wasn't about being the 23rd
guy in that chair I started realizing
man just by going to war with myself
every day and putting these challenges
and these goals and these obstacles
these insurmountable obstacles so it
wasn't about losing 106 pounds me losing
five pounds was an accomplishment me
losing 10 pounds and then 50 pounds and
the more I did the more I gain
confidence and then the more I gain
comments the more I realize
these guys can't do what I'm doing right
now I have no coach had no trainer had
no money I know how to lose weight I had
no knowledge of what I was doing I was
just working
I was just sacrificing and then through
that all these different tools started
coming up but I would have never found
these tools
if I didn't put myself in a very
uncomfortable place we all look for
toughness we all want it but we look for
it in a comfortable environment
you will not find toughness
in a comfortable environment and rule
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is deal with
negativity with garyvee people need
rewiring
wired I'll give you one that can help a
lot of times I talk like this you're
like all right give me something here
you go
I'll help you so much this is real talk
write down a piece of paper
old school note's on the iPhone paper
write down a piece of paper the people
you spend the most time with
then look at it
and score them on positivity and
negativity
if they're the most positive
they're ten if they're negative there
are one the
and anything in between
look at it and spend less time with the
people that have low scores
[Music]
I'm not saying cut your mama out
I'm saying limited a little bit
if your mother is the most negative
person in your life don't talk to her
six times a day
talk to her once every two days
that's just the way life is you are the
byproduct of the positivity and the
negativity that you consume
but I get a lot of enjoyment of
interacting
with people that are very mean to me
um because I always dream that showing
that level of compassion and kindness
back to them might be the seed that
shows them that there is goodness and
it's possible and might be the beginning
of them getting out of that place
yeah I mean I think you know but I don't
think I'd kill them with kindness I
think of it more as I motivate them with
empathy
I'm not worried about anybody loving or
hating me
so I'm not killing them with kindness
for me I'm trying to show an act of
kindness with the hope that it might
trigger an opportunity for them to build
perfect thank you
I think there's something very important
in that combo let me explain what I
what's very important one of the great
things of being good with
negativity is you're also then good with
positivity I get way more love than I
get hate
and it's actually very dangerous to
believe it
when everyone is telling you you're the
greatest of all time there's something
very scary that can happen in that you
could lose your humility yeah one of the
great things about not hearing either is
you just stay in your spot
you know one of the reasons I like about
the fact that I put both fingers in my
ear and I just go is really not about
being able to deal with hate it's
actually being able to control the
love so that it keeps me in a humble
place instead of getting high in my own
Supply
the reticular activity system the RAS
for short
um for if you don't know what it is
picture a hair net over your brain that
is a live Network and the RAS is a
filter and it has a huge job and it is a
filter that blocks out 99 of the world
and lets in about you know point zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero one
percent and it is always changing there
are only four things Tom that get
through the hair net on your head the
sound of your name and you've
experienced this because you've been
walking through a crowd you're like did
somebody say my name right the second
sale party effect cocktail party effect
the second thing that gets through is
any sort of threat so if you hear a loud
noise and you go like this there are
lots of noises you didn't hear but the
loud when you kind of duck because it's
a threat the third thing is when your
partner is interested in sex with either
you or someone else that's why you're
like why are you checking that person
out right you know because the brain is
letting that information in the fourth
thing and this is where the
transformation
big ants
your brain will let in anything that it
believes is important to you the
zygarnic effect is the documented fact
that when something is important to you
and I'll explain what that means
your brain opens up a checklist in your
mind
and now your brain once it puts this
item on your checklist it will store the
checklist in your subconscious it's
encoded in your Ras and your mind is now
on the alert to spot things related to
it
the way that you make yourself feel like
something is important is your nervous
system goes on alert while you're
thinking about it you're either super
excited about something oh this is super
important or this is the trauma effect
you go on alert and you have something
really bad happen which is why
things continue to bring it up
throughout the rest of your life so when
you understand that if something's
important to you your filter will change
in real time how you see the world you
now know how to change your brain to
work for you and looking for hearts is
the way I'm going to prove to you that
this happens I want to give you one
other example because everybody's
experienced this if you've ever gone
shopping for a new car or you've dreamed
about having a new car what happens
immediately when you get excited about
that new car is your mind goes zygon
artifact oops okay Tom wants the new
Bronco that's cool so what do you see
now you see Broncos everywhere now they
were always there but your mind is
letting them in because the zygon
artifact
is now mated on a checklist it's changed
the res and so I am going to prove to
you that it is unbelievably cool that
you can change the way that you view the
World by looking for heart-shaped
objects so tomorrow when you wake up
you're going to start your day by
high-fiving yourself in the mirror I
want you to examine what the resistance
about because you're going to start to
then on be able to unpack what's holding
you back then you're going to go out in
the world and just like tell your mind I
want to see a heart today look for a
rock look for a leaf look in your like
lattes there a little shape there is
there an oil stain on the floor and when
you see one stop and go
I I just I like there's a scavenger hunt
I never would have seen that before
thank you brain now your brain's like
more Hearts you will start to see hearts
everywhere and when you can start to
train your brain and realize whoa this
is actually a cool thing this is
high-fiving your mind when you can see
hearts you can now go wait a minute if I
can change what I see based on what I
tell it
maybe if I got serious about not
constantly saying I'm a failure I
wouldn't attach that or see it
everywhere maybe if I got serious about
saying I can figure anything out this is
happening for a reason instead of I'm
you say okay I'm gonna learn something
with this it changes the way your brain
filters everything
and this is such an important piece to
the book because we've all had the
experience where you love somebody
deeply
and you see all their incredible
attributes and all they see is failure
or all they see is the weight that they
can't lose and it doesn't matter what
you say it doesn't matter what kind of
pep talk or support you give them
your loved one still only sees what they
hate about themselves blame the filter
in your brain you have been bitching
about your appearance or the weight on
your scale the fact that you're a
failure for so long your brain believes
it's important to you to see reasons why
this is true
and one of the things I gotta say about
this and everything in the book is the
tools are simple Tom
but it's super important to say
just because you change and start
celebrating yourself it's not going to
make the weight disappear suddenly
it doesn't change the number on the
scale overnight what it changes is you
and that changes your ability
to deal with the problems and the issues
you want to change in your life if you
think that your thoughts have something
to do with your future just from a
theoretical standpoint that your
thoughts Create Your Destiny and you
think sixty to seventy thousand thoughts
in one day and ninety percent of those
thoughts are the same thoughts as the
day before well then your life isn't
going to change very much as long as
you're thinking the same way and those
those same thoughts lead to the same
choices the same choices lead to the
same behaviors the same behaviors create
the exact same experiences and we
anticipate the same feelings or emotions
from those experiences and those
emotions are the payoff that drive our
very same thoughts well our biology our
neuroscircuitry neural chemistry our
hormones and even our gene expression
will be equal to how we think how we act
and how we feel and how we think how we
act and how we feel is called our
personality and our personality creates
our personal reality that's it so the
present personality who's listening to
this show has created the present
personal reality called their life so if
you can latch on to this idea if you
want to create a new life a new personal
reality you got to change your
personality which means you better start
thinking about what you've been thinking
about and changing it you begin to
become conscious of your unconscious
actions or habits or behaviors and
modify them
and then we have to begin to look at the
emotions that we live by every single
day
that'll keep us connected to the past
and decide do these emotions belong in
our future so most people are trying to
create a new personal reality as the
same personality and it doesn't work you
literally have to become someone else so
the principle of Neuroscience says that
nerve cells that fire together wire
together you keep thinking the same way
making the same choices demonstrating
the same habits creating the same
experiences that stamp the same networks
of neurons into the same patterns all
for the familiar feeling called you and
you do that for 10 years on end you're
going to begin to hardwire certain
patterns in your brain that becomes your
identity and by the time we're 35 years
old it kind of becomes fixed right and
psychology used to say that you can't
change that but we now know that you can
so then that kind of box in the brain
that is the habit of ourselves it's a
we're 95 percent of the time running a
series of programs so then sitting and
doing the work had we have to become
disentangled from those programs and so
the moment you decide to do something
differently or make a new choice but
most people don't want to face is that
discomfort and that that discomfort that
that uncertainty that lack of
predictability the that that that
unknown is what people are afraid of
because they'd rather live in guilt at
least they can predict who they're going
to be then take a chance in possibility
so when a person begins to understand
this and you say well
how long have you been this way and they
say I've been like this for 35 years and
you say why 35 years because 35 years
ago I had this one event well the
stronger the emotion you feel from
reaction from that event the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
the brain Narrows its focus and freezes
the image and takes a snapshot and
that's called a memory right so then
forget the memory just overcome the
emotion because it's the emotion that
keeps you anchored to the past so that
sounds really good theoretically but
when you step out into that unknown into
that void
the body really is in a habit and what a
habit is when the body becomes the mind
or if you're thinking about that past
event and is producing an emotion well
you need an image and a feeling to start
the conditioning process so the body's
either conditioned into the familiar
past or it's hardwired in the
predictable future because it wakes up
every single day and runs through the
same series of routine actions so the
present moment then becomes the unknown
when people start feeling that
discomfort today they rather get on
their cell phone and call someone or get
up and say I can't meditate or you know
I have too much to do they excuse
themselves they return back into that
familiar feeling because the body's
actually telling the brain The Habit is
when the body becomes the mind so the
body stepping out into the unknown and
says ooh I'd rather feel guilty I'd
rather feel unhappy then be in this this
conference so then at least then when
they return back to that familiar
feeling then they feel safe so they step
out in the unknown and the body starts
influencing the mind saying you can
start tomorrow you're too busy it's your
mother's fault you know it's your
culture's fault I don't have enough
money this isn't going to work
those are the programs in there that are
standing in the way between you and your
future so then nerve cells that no
longer fire together no longer wire
together so the act of observing those
states of Mind and Body
means you're no longer the program
you're the Consciousness observing that
program so so then
to meditate it means to become familiar
with so as you become familiar with
those thoughts you become conscious of
how you speak you become aware of how
you act you notice how you're feeling
the more conscious you become of those
unconscious programs the less
unconscious you'll go in your waking day
why because it's not enough to just have
a great meditation and get up and get on
the freeway and get in traffic and
getting stressed you just return back to
the old self again our job then
is to sustain that modified State of
Mind and Body the entire day and if you
can get ready because something
different or unusual is going to begin
to happen in your life and it will come
as a coincidence or synchronicity and
that's breadcrumbs from the Divine
saying you're on the path just keep
doing it there'll be another one just
keep staying in that energy and so
teaching people then to understand that
there's a formula that we now know that
if you apply that formula you'll begin
to see those changes and now as people
are doing it more and more
effectively the results are going up as
well we just had Bond University they
just took a whole bunch of my brain
scans from 10 years ago
huge clinical study a lot of analysis
and and they're Blown Away by the speed
in which
the community can change brain or heart
coherence they they know how to do it
it's not
something that's that's separate from
them they've practiced it enough times
that they they now know how to do it so
what's the significance of that well
really simple
in your life if you start returning back
to the same reactions to the same people
and circumstances you're returning back
to the old self so you got to stay
conscious in your life and and if you're
not being defined by a vision of the
future then you're left with the
memories of the past and you will be
predictable in your life so Crossing
that River of change from the old self
to the new self there's a neurological
biological chemical hormonal a genetic
death of the old self but if you teach
people there's something on the other
side they won't give up on themselves
they'll keep going so there's enough
evidence to encourage people and you
can't tell me you're too old to do this
work you can't tell me you're too sick
to do this work you can't tell me you
had a turbulent past or or that you're
too overweight or too underweight or too
out of shape or you can't even tell me
that you've never meditated before in
fact some of our greatest
scans or people who just have never
meditated before that are trying to do
anything they just follow instructions
so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible and they
go all in not 50 and not 60 and when we
do a week-long event we got a thousand
people or 1500 people and they are all
in and that when they start getting
Beyond themselves that first day or
second day once they start getting
Beyond themselves and that magic starts
to happen then I have no idea I can't
predict how what's gonna happen next and
it's usually pretty pretty exciting it
dawned on me that
sometimes we don't have the right frames
when we're doing something
and we don't give things the right
meanings
and let me explain what I mean to you by
that
when we start something new
I think sometimes we forget
that anything that is new to our brain
may be exciting and may release dopamine
the neurochemical that he knows the
reward neurochemical
and we feel good because we've taken on
this new Endeavor whether it's a new
language whether it's retraining our
brain whether it's um starting to
exercise or eating better or committing
to doing something that's of benefit to
us or even stopping something
now the very nature of how our brain
works is that patterns that have been
repeated over you know months and years
are the dominant patterns in our brain
and therefore it's easier for our brain
to activate and follow through to
completion on those patterns it's like
having a you know highway system that's
been built it's easy for the cars to go
faster on the highway system well same
thing is true with our brain and the
neural networks and Pathways so the
pathways are the easiest for the
chemicals to travel across and release
the
neurochemicals you know that make us
feel good or make us feel fearful or
make us feel apprehensive or doubtful
Etc are the ones that are the easiest
for our brain to activate and follow
through on okay part one
so that means that a new pattern meaning
stopping something or starting something
requires a little bit more of the
brain's energy and the Brain wants to
conserve energy so what is our brain
naturally going to do and the answer is
it's going to resist why because it
wants to preserve the energy that may be
required in case there's a saber-toothed
tiger that comes around from you know
the the woods to try and kill you so
we're in this energy conservation
mindset without even knowing it our
biology is geared towards doing things
that are easy for us not things that
require energy right glucose
so why am I sharing this with you well
as you're you know on your journey of
brain training upgrading your Knowledge
and Skills taking actions probably
different actions that you were taking
to achieve the results that you want
more and better results from of
um it requires you accessing higher
cortical functions and a higher level of
awareness is especially pay close
attention especially
when you feel resistance now I came out
here I still have my workout gloves on
because as I was doing uh some ab work
as I was doing you know some bench press
and flies for my chest one of the things
that dawned on me is most people do
things that they are comfortable doing
but in order to get stronger from a
cardiovascular perspective you have to
challenge yourself mix up your routines
you've got to go a little bit longer a
little bit harder
you know on the days that you want to
expand your capabilities so in the world
of uh you know doing weights for
strength training or building muscle
there are certain techniques to use in
certain strategies use including rest
right muscles build built in the rest
phase so let me explain what I'm talking
about I think you know where I'm going
with this
when I let's say do a bench press or fly
or I walk up a hill
the place where it's the hardest where
there's resistance where I want to quit
and stop and I'm breathing heavier I
just can't do another rep that's the
point of the growth
and the more you practice at that place
right the resistance the point of I want
to quit I can't do it anymore that is
how you expand your capacity resistance
happens
when you're at the edges of Your
Capacity now it could be mental edges
emotional edges physical edges Financial
edges and how does it show up it shows
up as stress
right stress so stress happens when your
current capacity let me repeat
stress happens when your current
capacity exceeds
the demand
your current capacity exceeds the demand
so how do you increase demand I'm sorry
how do you increase capacity well you
feel the edges and go one more you feel
the tension and keep doing it you feel
the desire to quit but then you do as
much as you can and as you do as much as
you can you get mentally stronger
physically stronger emotionally stronger
so when I feel like let's say quitting I
just say just a little bit more when I
don't feel like it I say I know but just
do a little bit why because I want to
override my natural and your natural
propensity to want to quit to want to
stop it's natural
but I don't want to be natural I want to
be Supernatural I don't want to be
ordinary I want to be extraordinary and
that's that little extra does that make
sense so as you're training your brain
as you have videos to watch upgrade your
Knowledge and Skills as you have events
to attend you know to to connect to to
listen to learn to expand
if you catch yourself thinking or
feeling I don't feel like it I'm too
tired not today tomorrow that's the
language okay that the brain uses the
rationalizations the rational lies that
your brain my brain everybody's brain
uses to keep you in your comfort zone
well guess what everything you want
financially in your relationship
health-wise is just outside your comfort
zone if you keep challenging and
expanding your mental emotional physical
spiritual Financial Comfort zones you
expand as a human being and you start
fulfilling more of your potential than
standing on the edge of it hoping and
praying and wishing that you can have
greater better results you want to be a
professional baseball player yeah right
yeah but then you got an injury I did
similar to me so you never made it to
the big league so did you play minor
league I did yeah and I played division
one college baseball too yeah I like
every guy like you and I talked about
this last time it's always our injuries
that ended our careers I probably it
probably put me into a premature place
where I was going anyways you weren't
going to be in The Bigs for I wasn't I
played enough baseball with guys who
ended up in the big leagues to know my
limitations yeah so like anything in
life things happen for you not to you
that injury happened for me certainly
didn't seem like it at the time but it
got me out of that and into something
like what we're talking about now that
completely changed my life so yeah but
yeah I want to be an athlete for sure
all my life all your life that was my
mask and then when it exactly and then
when it ended your identity was like who
am I right yes lost yeah like a lot you
and I were just talking this before we
went on yeah you know our professional
athlete friends were their career
changes I went into a like anybody like
whatever your dream is when the first
one ends it doesn't happen whether that
be a relationship it could be your
marriage it ends it was a dream right or
a business venture or a sport I went
into a pretty good depression and uh and
how old were you at the time 21 22 and I
ended up you know it's because people
always see the after like the house or
whatever house or whatever the material
things are but I ended up bad man I
ended up to press I ended up moving back
at home with my parents I was living in
the city I remember I was living in this
sleeping in the same bed I grew up in
with the same teddy bear the same
posters I was like going back in time
like six years on back where I was
totally unemployed and uh couldn't find
work didn't have the motivation to get
up and find a job just sort of eating
out of their fridge and laying around
all day so that's where I was many many
years ago after baseball and when you
realize things in your life happen for
you truly especially in hindsight
everybody knows it in hindsight right if
you look back at any disaster tragedy
most people look back five ten years
they think that happened for me that was
actually a good thing and so I was
unemployed I couldn't find a job and my
old man my dad was the best dad role
model he could ever have in your life
hard-working man good man it's better
man than me has more Integrity than me
he's the best man I've ever known but
when I was growing up my dad had a
drinking problem and so my dad had
gotten sober recently and he was going
to these meetings and he comes home from
one of his meetings and says there's a
guy at my meeting who can get you a job
that's right down the street in San
Dimas you're going to be working with
kids doesn't pay anything at six bucks
an hour but you're gonna get this damn
job so show up there tomorrow morning 8
A.M ask for Tim so I walked I drive down
there it's a place called McKinley Home
For Boys little did I know that would
alter my entire life that was the most
significant thing that happened to me
and so I walk in there
I said I'm Ed mylett I'm here for the
job you're like what job I'm like I
don't know just my dad told me to show
up here yeah I need to ask for Tim
they're like
we have no idea who the hell Tim is
what's his last name I said I I don't I
don't know it's the last name and
they're like so you showed up for a job
that you don't know what it is and you
don't know who it is it's hiring you I'm
like here's what I know he's an
alcoholic I'm like oh damn yeah we know
that too and so they bring me to the guy
and he says uh you're hired let's go
look literally shakes my hand and you're
hired and he introduces me to these
eight boys that were my boys they were
seven eight and nine years old and
basically I lived with these boys these
precious boys and we ended up adding a
few more my boys were all Wards of the
Court they were all molested by family
where parents were in prison and so they
had no family and so my whole life
changed all of a sudden these became on
this 22 year old guy these guys become
my sons wow and I did holidays with them
I did birthdays with them I lived with
them literally in a home or like a
literally McKinley is a massive campus
full of children that have been
displaced from their homes that live in
individual like Cottages like a foster
care facility massive though really yep
all boys it's in San Dimas here and wow
it just altered my life man because I
I'd been an athlete had a huge ego had
that mask I wanted to compete I wanted
to win I wanted attention I wanted
recognition first time literally in my
life I went
well I I love helping people I love
making a difference and my boys were
just come from horrendous situations and
so just I always say this all the time
and I have those eyes too you have them
I think sometimes kids who grow up with
some dysfunction they just have
different eyes yeah they just have these
eyes that are these boys all were
different but they had that same eyes
they just like man love me believe in me
you know care about me and I had those
eyes because I grew up in an alcoholic
family and my whole life changed I just
went wow I love I actually love helping
people and being involved in people's
lives I didn't know that because
everything was you're great you're great
you know what it is when you're an
athlete right everything's about you
you're amazing free dinners free this
you're a stud all of a sudden I was in a
stud and all of a sudden it wasn't about
me it was about these 10 boys that ended
up being 10 of them and it just altered
my life man and so after that I ran into
the financial business that I ended up
in but I would have completely flunked
out of that Financial business had I not
been with my boys for those years and I
was there for two years two years yeah
man like eight hours a day type of thing
or sometimes more sometimes 16 18. I I
think about I'm not kidding you I think
about my boys and my experience there
two of them are still very close with me
uh every day there's a moment where I
reflect on that it altered me completely
like what I wanted to do I always wanted
to be famous and Rich and successful and
now I just wanted to serve yeah I wanted
to help the little did I find out I
could get rich and famous and all that
other stuff I thought I wanted through
serving people you don't have to
necessarily have done anything wrong for
things to get completely out of control
it's a terrifying Doctrine but it's not
a hopeless Doctrine because it still
says that there's a way forward there's
a pathway forward and the pathway
forward is to adopt a motive being that
has some nobility so that you can
tolerate yourself and perhaps even have
some respect for yourself as someone
who's capable of standing up in the face
of that terrible vulnerability and
suffering and that the pathway forward
as far as the existentialists are
concerned is by well certainly by the
avoidance of Deceit particularly in
language but also by the adoption of
responsibility for the conditions of
existence and some attempt on your part
to actually Rectify them and the thing
that's so interesting about that is
there we have two as far as I'm
concerned
and some of this is from Clinical
experience you know if you take people
and I've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of you know that
they know they need to overcome in order
to meet their goals their self-defined
goals if you can teach people to stand
up in the face of the things they're
afraid of they get stronger
and you don't know what the upper limits
to that are because you might ask
yourself like if for 10 years if you
didn't avoid doing what you knew you
needed to do by the deaf by your own
definitions right within the value
structure that you've created to the
degree that you've done that what would
you be like
well you know there are remarkable
people who come into the world from time
to time and there are people who do find
out over decades-long periods what they
could be like if they were who they were
if they said if they spoke their being
forward
and they get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it and of course that's
a terrible thing to admit and it's a
terrible thing to consider but there's
real promise in it right because it
means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world in a number
another way that you could act in the
world so what it would reflect back to
you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now my experience
is with people that we're probably
running at about 51 percent of our
capacity something I mean you can think
about this yourselves I often ask
undergraduates
how many hours a day you waste or how
many hours a week you waste and the
classic answer is something like four to
six hours a day you know inefficient
studying watching things on YouTube that
not only do you not want to watch that
you don't even care about that make you
feel horrible about watching after
you're done that's probably four hours
right there now you think well that's 20
25 hours a week it's 100 hours a month
that's two and a half full work weeks
it's half a year of work weeks per year
and if your time is worth
twenty dollars an hour which is a
radical underestimate it's probably more
like 50 if you think about it in terms
of deferred wages if you're wasting 20
hours a week you're wasting 50 000 a
year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young wasting
fifty thousand dollars a year is a way
bigger catastrophe than it would be for
me to waste it because I'm not going to
last nearly as long and so if your life
isn't everything it could be you could
ask yourself well what would happen if
you just stopped wasting the
opportunities that are in front of you
you be who knows how much more efficient
10 times more efficient 20 times more
efficient that's the Pareto distribution
you have no idea how efficient efficient
people get it's completely it's off the
charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time not only do they
not do what they should to make things
better they actively attempt to make
things worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package if people stopped
really really trying just to make things
worse we have no idea how much better
they would get just because of that
so there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability social
judgment both of which are are are our
major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility that they know they
should adopt it isn't merely that your
fate depends on whether or not you get
your act together and to what degree you
decide that you're going to live out
your own genuine being it isn't only
your fate it's the fate of everyone that
you're networked with and so you know
you think well
there's nine billion seven billion
people in the world we're going to Peak
at about 9 billion by the way and then
it'll decline rapidly but seven billion
people in the world and who are you
you're just one little dust moat among
that seven billion and so it really
doesn't matter what you do or don't do
but that's simply not the case it's the
wrong model because you're at the center
of a network you're a node in a network
of course that's even more true now that
we have social media you'll you'll know
a thousand people at least over the
course of your life and they'll know a
thousand people each and that puts you
one person away from a million and two
persons away from a billion
and so that's how you're connected and
the things you do they're like dropping
a stone in a pond the ripples move
outward and they affect things in ways
that you can't fully comprehend and it
means that the things that you do and
that you don't do are far more important
than you think
and so if you act that way of course the
terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do
and you might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter but I mean if
you really ask yourself would you be so
sure if you had the choice I can live
with no responsibility whatsoever the
price I pay is that nothing matters
or I can reverse it and everything
matters
but I have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that it's not so
obvious to me that people would take the
meaningful path
now when you say well nihilists suffered
dreadfully because there's no meaning in
their life and they still suffer yeah
but the advantage is they have no
responsibility
so that's the payoff and I actually
think that's the motivation say well I
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe
maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is some meaningless
suffering but you can always whine about
that and people will feel sorry for you
and you have the option of taking the
pathway of the Martyr so that's a pretty
good deal All Things Considered
especially when they are when the
alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well with
sojournitzen figured out and so many
people in the 20th century it's not just
him even though he's the best example is
that if you live a pathological life you
pathologize your society and if enough
people do that then it's hell
really
really
and you can read the gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit or even more
importantly if it's a light if it's a
place you'd like to visit and take all
your family and friends because that's
what happened in the 20th century your
challenges don't only make you stronger
they allow you to serve better I think
the default
answer for a lot of people is that your
challenges make you stronger your
challenges will you know to grow muscle
you have to break you have to break your
muscle first and all of these obstacles
are put in your way allow you to have a
a better life they're making you
stronger they're making you more
powerful and that's all true yes and
the thing that helps me the most is just
tying it back to service because I think
you know humor to build to serve you are
built to serve when you can connect the
challenge that you're going through as
something that's then going to inspire
and help other people
at least for me it always gives me a lot
more strength and a lot more courage to
do the thing that I need to do as
opposed to just being about me getting
stronger I find a lot of times me
getting stronger is not enough it's not
enough of a reason compared to it's
going to help somebody else as well so
you know that's you hope this video
helps you as well so I think about
when I was doing my tour 2019 and I
broke my neck it was one of the most
challenging times in my life and that
it's already hard enough I'm already you
know on the road report of the year on
the road 90 straight days me Nina my
camera mandani and there were a lot of
challenges in making that whole tour
happen and new city every four days and
all of the stuff that goes into you know
was my first ever tour and then I broke
my neck two-thirds of the way through
so as if things weren't hard enough now
I break my neck I can't drive anymore uh
I'm in insane amounts of pain I have a
concussion uh and I'm I'm still making
videos I I struggled with the decision
this is a real decision do I do I quit
the tour or not do I quit the tour do I
go home
there's still another month on the road
it's not just me it's also Nina who has
to do a lot more work now she's got to
drive this giant Suburban across the
country uh Danny the camera guy has to
do a lot more work you know it's a lot
of stress I'm basically out of
commission and all I could do was talk
which is great for speaking but it sucks
for everything else so what do we do
the thing that made me want to at least
try to keep going I didn't know that I
would go for another month but I thought
let's just do the next city let's just
do the next city let's go to Kansas City
Kansas City was the next stop
let's go to Kansas City and see what
happens
what got me through it was
thinking about somebody in the audience
thinking about one of you guys who is
struggling with something physically up
until that point I dealt with a lot of
mental issues mental issues mindset
issues things like believe in you not
good enough lack of self-worth you don't
have a message to share imposter
syndrome all of those things right even
here we're filming we're about to go
through a car wash uh we're we're next
so we're probably gonna get some crazy
noise I have to talk loud I used to
be so worried about that stuff that I
wouldn't I wouldn't feel like oh I can't
film going to a car wash you know the
noise whatever now I look at it as
opportunities like let's go like that's
not a good enough reason maybe the video
quality sucks I you know I hope not
um maybe you can't hear me loud enough I
hope not but but not letting those
things get in your way because that
stuff happens all the time you know like
that stuff happens all the time look
we're
[Music]
in this car wash we're next depending on
how long that guy ahead of us takes you
might you might see it in this video I
dealt with a lot of those mindset issues
those lack of belief issues those
worthiness issues and I I battled them
and I've been through them and
yeah have a few lessons to share
and over the years of me trialing and
failing and you know 20 plus years of
doing this
my hope is to make the path a little bit
easier for you so that you don't have to
struggle as much as I did the path can
be a little bit sooner a little bit
faster a little bit less painful right
but I'd never been through anything
really physical you know I've broken my
toe
I remember breaking my toe
uh and then going for a run and I was
doing Instagram live at the times like a
light run fast Jog and I like my toe was
hurting so much and I just kept powering
through I didn't later realize I broke
my toe but that's not really anything
major right you know if somebody's going
through something physical and major
it's like you broke your toe come on
it's not a big deal and so I never felt
like I could
serve or push people who
had a physical limitation
I had a physical kind of injury because
I'd never gone through it and I don't
feel right pushing people on things that
I haven't experienced in some form
myself right
so here I am 2009 2019 now I break my
neck now I'm having concussion I'm in
more pain I've ever been in my life
concussion if you haven't been through
it is just devastating because it's not
just the physical pain of not being able
to move your body and you know neck and
potential having spinal surgery which is
crazy scary but also not being able to
think clearly first for me I I value
that a lot like I love thinking you know
I love problem solving and not being
able to think clearly and just be a
vegetable on the couch all day was was
devastating so getting through that and
then deciding I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
going
I'm gonna at least try for the next stop
in Kansas City why
because if I can get through this
yes it's a challenge that will teach me
and make me stronger and I have a lesson
that I can learn from it but
if I can get through this then hopefully
can serve as an inspiration for other
people who are going through something
physical as well but it's not just a
mindset issue but they have physical
limitations
you know the first couple the first
night in the hospital I was a you know a
train wreck then I came home and uh to
our Airbnb they let me out of the
hospital and I remember two specific
Moments One trying to get into the car
so we're at the hospital I get
discharged I'm excited to go home fresh
air oh my gosh it's amazing and I have
this neck brace on I can't move I have
very low flexibility and I'm now the
passenger I'm not allowed to drive
because I can't turn my head so Nina has
to Nina has to drive and I'm in the
parking lot of the hospital
and
I'm trying to get into the passenger
side I'm in the passenger seat right now
in my car I'm trying to get into the
passenger side of the car and I can't
and it hurts too much and I get to the
point where I have one foot in the car
and one foot out of the car
and it's a Suburban so this is a giant
step up to get in
and I remember being so
I was in so much pain
that I couldn't go forward into the car
I didn't have the strength and every
time I lift it off it it killed
everything in my body the whole like all
my back up into my neck everything was
in massive pain but I also couldn't get
back down
because that was hurting too much too so
I was in I was stuck in this limbo if I
can't go forward I can't go back
[Music]
Nina's trying to you know push me up to
get me in and then I remember just
crying
I'm in the parking lot of that oh we're
going in the car wash I'm in the parking
lot I'm gonna have to talk louder I'm in
the parking lot
of the hospital and I'm crying
out of frustration and I can't remember
the last time I was that frustrated that
I just broke down and cried and I I
didn't know what to do next everything
hurt I can't move forward I can't move
backwards I'm just overwhelmed by pain
and frustration and I'm crying in the
parking lot of the hospital
eventually Nina
just pushes me in
one hand on each butt cheek and like in
you go and I got it and it hurt but but
then I was in
and that was just
an overwhelming moment
and then I remember that night
here we go car wash
that night
uh it was I mean I can't sleep it's
terrible i've got you know neck brace on
I'm not used to sleeping with it I'm in
massive pain and it's it's three in the
morning
and I have to go to the bathroom
and so I'm sitting I I can get myself to
sit up they taught me in the hospital
how to push yourself from
um
lying down to
to sitting up oh look here comes look at
the foam look at that guys how to go
from lying down to sitting up without
hurting yourself too much like
minimizing the pain as much as possible
so they taught me how to do that
so three in the morning I have to go to
the bathroom I get up uh I push myself
into the seating position
I'm starting to feel dizzy I have a
concussion right I'm starting to feel
dizzy I can't see anything because it's
really dark and
I'm worried that if I stand up I might
fall over
how I got the concussion was I fainted I
fainted my head on the wall and then
cracked my my the back of my neck open
I'm worried that if I stand up I might
faint and I might fall over again
and I Nina's asleep next to me
look at this
were you sleeping on the floor Linda's
joining in no you're on the bed we're on
the floor
she was afraid she's gonna wake me up I
mean bless Nina's Hearts I mean she had
no sleep during this whole time too
right so she's asleep it's three in the
morning and I and I
I don't want to wake her up
one because I feel bad for her because
she hasn't slept at all but also I feel
helpless I feel so helpless
that I mean all this pain and I can't
even go I can't even go to the bathroom
by myself like I need help to go to the
bathroom I felt so helpless and I said
it's it's not worth it for me to get up
and and potentially like if I fall
that's that's no bueno right I'm back to
the hospital probably if I fall so I
wake up Nina and I mean it may not seem
like a big deal but it it felt like a
big deal like I felt just helpless
and so I had yeah I woke her up she
helped me go to the bathroom and you
know I did my business and went back to
sleep but
those two moments in particular were the
most painful moments of that whole
experience
it's the best uh
and and the thing that got me through it
the thing that gave me the motivation
was that
hopefully somebody else who's going
through some kind of painful moment
right now
we'll be able to resonate with this and
be inspired by this whether it's
actually true or not it was a story that
I was telling myself I told myself
somebody's going to be inspired by this
and I still made videos and my next
round of videos I couldn't do the whole
thing so Nina did some of it I did some
of it
um and I'm sitting there I'm I'm now
overweight because I'm uh you know I
haven't been able to work out
um I haven't been eaten as clean as I
was normally I got a giant scab if you
look at some of those old videos I have
this huge scab on my forehead again
normally like oh my gosh I got this
giant scab on my you might be worried
about a little pimple look at this giant
scab coming down my forehead it looked
like Harry Potter the thing that gets me
through it is
other people
who have some kind of issue like to
having a bad hair day or a pimple on
their face might be inspired by this to
go and take action what Nina has a
paintball whatever you want to show
everybody your pimple on your forehead
again whether it's true or not it was a
story that I was telling myself that
somebody else is going to be inspired by
this and it's going to allow them to go
and do their thing
um now fast forward
make the videos we release the videos a
lot of people were inspired by it a lot
of people did message me DM me email me
tell me in future interviews you know I
was I was telling myself I couldn't do
this because of X because I had a
headache
and here you are doing your videos with
a concussion
giant Scout on your face neck brace in
massive pain breaking your neck and I
told myself what I have no excuse I'm
gonna go do my thing because Evan did
his thing
but again whether it was true or not
the thing that got me to get through the
challenge in a way that I'm proud of
myself for
was the connection to service
that it's not just here to make me
stronger which it did made me incredibly
like I can't believe I did that that guy
is still in me that I could go and do
that again hopefully they'll break my
neck again but I could do that
It Made Me Stronger but even more
valuable
is me feeling like this is gonna mean
something to somebody else so whatever
challenge you're going through
understand that yes you know your
purpose comes from your pain
this will make you a better person
but the thing that will help you get
through it at least in my experience is
connecting to somebody else
that there are tons of people out there
who are also struggling with the same
thing that you are struggling with right
now and when you get through it your
story will be an inspiration for them
your journey through it
will motivate them to have the courage
to show up for their lives as well and
when you can actually connect it to
service I think everything is better you
are built to serve we made it through
the car wash
[Laughter]
good job Nina hopefully that uh you
heard all that stuff and it was valuable
and life-changing and if not I love you
anyway
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
more incredible inspiring speeches check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there my original teacher
was Jim Rohn when I met him when I was
17. and I wanted to know why all my
fathers were broke because they were
good men and I loved all four of my
fathers and I remember him saying Tony
we're all equal as Souls